a particular measurement outcome a the state of Z is given by the expression shown on the screen which is what we get
by normalizing The Matrix we just saw a moment ago and that's the same thing as dividing the matrix by the probability
for a to appear I should mention that this only makes sense if the probability is non zero because otherwise we're
dividing by zero but that's okay because we don't need to concern ourselves with things that don't happen in this part of
the lesson we'll discuss a simple but fundamental theorem about measurements known as Neymar's
theorem in short what it says is that any measurement can be implemented as the figure on the screen
suggests putting this in words a given General measurement on a system X can be implemented in the following way
we first introduce an initialized workspace system y whose classical states are the possible measurement outcomes which we're assuming are
numbered 0 through n minus one then a unitary operation U is performed on the pair
YX and then a standard basis measurement is performed on y so everything is basically set in
stone here except for the choice of U and what the theorem says is that it is in fact possible to choose this unitary
operation U so that the probabilities for the different outcomes always agree with the given General
measurement now let's see how Neymar's theorem is proved and it isn't difficult we just need to make a good choice for
the unitary operation U and verify that it works but first we need a basic fact
from Matrix Theory which is that for any positive semi-definite Matrix P there's always a unique positive semi-definite
Matrix Q such that Q s is equal to P in general there could be many matrices that squared to give us P but
there's always just one of them that's positive semi-definite the notation we use to denote this Matrix is the square root of
p and that's also how we refer to it in words if you want to calculate the square root of P for some positive
semi-definite Matrix P by the way you can do that by first calculating a spectral decomposition of p and then
replacing each of the igen values by its square root and leaving the igen vectors alone the igen values are all non-
negative so this makes sense and it's pretty easy to see that the Matrix we get is in fact positive semi-definite
and squares to P the fact that it's Unique is a different matter it's not difficult to
prove that using some basic facts about matrices but it's kind of tangential to the lesson and we'll just take that part
as being given and now that we have that Concept in hand it's pretty easy to spef ify a
unitary operation U that works any unitary Matrix that matches the pattern that's shown on the screen will in fact
work the first n columns assuming X has n classical States like before are obtained by stacking the square roots of
the matrices that describe the measurement on top of one another and the remaining columns can be whatever we
want it doesn't make any difference as long as the entire Matrix is unitary
and by the way if you're noticing a resemblance to the connection between Krauss and Stein spring representations of channels that's not coincidental and
in fact what we have here is essentially a special case of that where our cross matricies all happen to be positive
semi-definite so there are two things we need to check the first is that this choice of you actually works and the
second is that it's possible to choose the unspecified columns in a way that makes you unitary so let's start with the first
one here's the state that we start with the bottom system Y is initialized to the zero State while the top system
starts in the state row and then we perform U which means that we conjugate by
U we can write this all out in terms of block matrices as is shown on the screen we have U on the left UD dagger on the
right and K zero bra zero tensored with row in the middle which takes the form that we have here where we have Row in
the upper left hand corner and zeros everywhere else and if you think about this product for a moment it's evident that the
unspecified entries of you don't matter at all because they're always getting multiplied by zero entries of this
Matrix in the middle and if we work through the multiplication what we get is this
Matrix that's shown right here described as a block Matrix or alternatively we can express it using direct notation
like this that is in fact the more convenient form for us so let's focus in on this
expression and for the sake of convenience let's give this Matrix which is a density Matrix the name
Sigma the last step is the standard basis measurement on y so let's calculate the reduced state in y and
that's easy given the expression we have we simply Trace out X which corresponds to the second tensor
Factor so the probability for any given outcome a to appear is the diagonal entry corresponding to a we can write
that like this and it equals the trace of the square root of PA * row * the square
root of PA and by the cyclic property of the trace we get the trace of PA * row
which is what we were hoping for so the probabilities for the different outcomes to appear are correct they always agree
with the original measurement that we started with the second thing we need to check
is that it's possible to fill in the unspecified Columns of U in such a way that it becomes
unitary this follows from the fact that the first n columns which are the ones that are formed by the square roots of the matrices that describe the
measurement are orthonormal and that can be checked pretty directly the relevant details are here
on the screen so pause the video and take a few moments to think about that if you wish but as I suggested before
it's actually a special case of something that we encountered in the previous lesson and that is the
proof so far in the lesson we've kept our focus on destructive measurements meaning that there's no specification of
the postmeasurement quantum state of the system that was measured for a non-destructive measurement on the other hand there's
not only a classical measurement outcome but also a postmeasurement Quantum state of the system that was measured and as
we'll see there's a natural connection to Neymar's theorem there are in fact different ways to formulate non-destructive
measurements in mathematical terms but we'll start with one formulation that basically comes directly from Neymar's
theorem consider a general measurement meaning a destructive one described by a collection of positive semi-definite
matrices p 0 through PN minus one that's sum to the identity we can then turn this